if you take the Black Knight and we
might get a situation like this where
white has two pieces against a black
rook and a couple of Pawns very tense
and wow Wesley sacrifices Rook suddenly
drama on the board let's go back to the
game Magnus pushed upon taking advantage
of the fact this Pawn is pinned in the
center the black uh the white Pawn
cannot capture but Wesley gave up his
Rook giving up a rook and the whole idea
is suddenly if the Rook is captured
black would walk into a fork the queen
is attacked she only has one safe square
and suddenly this looks deadly a deadly
check why it's not coming in for the
kill coming into the attack but Magnus
reacted instantly of course he didn't
take this Rook he had foreseen this
trick and he gives up his Knight what a
weird move uh what a hard move to spot
but it looks quite a strong for black
suddenly the whole reason is uh if this
Knight is captured now then after Pawn
takes Rook suddenly the black queen is
no longer trapped she can swoop back and
defend this key Square no checks for the
White Knight
still looks scary I've got to say those
black squares those dark squares around
the